a major victory and one small step which
could see these shop workers
cashing in the supreme court says
lower-paid asda supermarket staff
predominantly women can compare their
line of work
to higher paid warehouse workers who are
mostly men they haven't won the right to
equal pay but this
is the green light to pursuing their
cause a relief
for former employee wendy great
one step but still a few more to go
we're not back in the victorian age
anymore we're in the 21st century
lawyers representing some 44 000 store
workers
say depot workers get between one pound
fifty and three pounds an hour more
they say their case with gender equality
at its heart
isn't about proving the roles are
similar but that the value of them is
the same
we now go on to argue that the roles are
of equal value
and that means that when you look at the
demands of the roles and the skills that
they need
and the training that they need and so
on that they are of equal value
this is one of the biggest equal pay
claims in the uk
private sector it's not just the workers
inside who will be affected this will
have repercussions
across the industry as a society we do
undervalue work that women tend to
dominate in so if you look at something
like the caring profession
which we've seen throughout the past
year has been an extraordinary force in
this country
massively underpaid for what they do and
that happens time and again throughout
so many sectors that
things that are perceived as women's
work is less well-paid
kate worked for the supermarket for
eight years as one of the claimants
she's determined to get compensation
we could be waiting sort of another
another four years you know even longer
possibly nobody nobody really knows and
i think that's
that's down to asda and how they choose
to proceed and but yeah we're prepared
to wait
a spokesperson from asda told us we are
defending these claims
because the pay in our stores and
distribution centres is the same for
colleagues doing the same jobs
regardless of their gender retail and
distribution
are very different sectors with their
own distinct skill sets
and pay rates both sides prepared for
the long fight ahead
in what will be a historic case ashley
harinac sky news